in 1995 Tony Hawk wins gold in the first
X Games and goes on to dominate the
decade in 1999 he cranks it up a notch
attempting a neverbe done trick the 900
a 900 is a 2 and 1 half spin rotation
sort of somersault in the air holding
onto your
skateboard the thing that makes it the
most challenging is that you are blind
to your Landing Zone
twice
00 I had no plans of doing 900 at thex
games I think it was the on-site
announcer Dave Duncan that said oh let's
see that 900 cuz he knew I'd been trying
it Tony's got a shot
it and so I just started trying it more
to appease the crowd and to appease Dave
on the mic like here's what it looks
like
9900 it's going
be
oh clest one
we're not worthy when you go up and
start flipping it was
like something inside me just said
you're either making this or they're
going to cart you off of the ramp to the
hospital those were the only two endings
to that night for
[Applause]
meyy the 900 was revolutionary cuz it
had never been done
before my heart was in my mouth I didn't
want him to be taken away to ambulance I
wanted him to
land one point I thought it wasn't
possible and it was just like I wasn't
going to get
[Music]
up and when he did it that Pier shook
when I made it I saw all my peers
rushing towards me and it was like that
that made it
real and that's how you achieve
legendary status it was big for the X
Games it was big for Tony Hawk it was
big for skateboard like today we'd say
it went viral you know and and that is
was really a seminal
[Music]
[Applause]
moment how you do now
if it weren for you people I would have
never made that I swear to
[Music]
God